the joke had always been one of these
days I'm going to rip open one of these
envelopes and the holy grail is going to
fall out it did
we're at the world famous Gold & Silver
Pawn Shop on the Fabulous Las Vegas
Strip believe it or not I have pawned
hundreds of Super Bowl rings but they
always pick them up the very first one I
ever actually got to own that's my 2001
Patriots Super Bowl ring the Brock
Williams he pawned the ring he didn't
sell it ok he was in Vegas and we know
what happens in Vegas he needed cash so
I think the guy in the night ship
actually offered him 10,000 but he only
won at 2600 because it's a lot less
expensive to pick it up that way I mean
he I'm sure he more than planned on
picking it up but then weird things
happen to this world what you don't see
on my television show is most people
just come down here to get loans you
know I would loan them money and then
they will come back later and pay me
back the money I loaned them plus some
interest we'd give people 141 days to
pick up their merchandise and after that
you know every morning there's a thing
called the defaults these people loans
people didn't pick up they defaulted on
it it's not my property there's
envelopes I'd have to go through and I
opened one up and I just poured it on my
desk in it but it made a big clunk and
I'm going like you've got to be kidding
me
we both kind of forgot about it and then
but one day it just falls out of the
envelope so this was the start of the
super blingy Super Bowl rings okay your
first Super Bowl ring is only supposed
to be 10 carat it's only was supposed to
weigh so much the only hat was supposed
to have so much in diamonds
well craft apparently says this are for
a Super Bowl win I wanna make the damn
ring any way I want that particular
Patriots ring is pretty gnarly I mean
it's got a lot of stones in it it's not
your typical Super Bowl ring by any
means to me it's one of the coolest
Super Bowl rings there ever was it's
14-karat white gold I think there's a
hundred and forty-three diamonds and
they use sapphire and rubies for the
logo I don't want to sell it because
what happens is is someone will come in
from say Boston and say hey he's got a
Super Bowl ring in the showcase he'll go
home
tell his friends don't wanna come at the
pawnshop and see it one of these days
I'm gonna sell that thing when he's not
around realistically a ring like that is
probably worth 25 and I have sold Super
Bowl rings for as much as $40,000
I put the ridiculous price of $100,000
on it which is way too much money but
someone wants to give me that I'll
actually sell it
I think I'd sell them from probably
around 60 there's a lot of guys out
there I'm sure would love to have it I
mean Dan Marino would probably love to
have it Tony Romo is probably going to
need to have
one day yeah it's a it's a lot easier
than actually winning one I guess